so your big assembly Theory paper was
published in nature congratulations
thanks it created uh I think it's fair
to say a lot of controversy but also a
lot of interesting discussion so maybe I
can try to summarize assembly Theory and
you tell me if I'm wrong okay for it so
assembly Theory says that if we look at
any object in the universe any object
that we can quantify how complex It Is
by trying to find the number of steps it
took to create it and also we can
determine if it was built by a process
akin to evolution by looking at how many
copies of the object there are yep
that's spot on y spot on spot on I was
not expecting that okay so let's go
through
definitions so there's a central
equation I'd love to uh talk about but
definition wise what is an
object um yeah an object so from so if
I'm going to try to be as meticulous as
possible objects need to be
finite um and they need to be
decomposable into
subunits all human-made artifacts are
objects um is a planet an object
probably yes in the if you scale out so
an object is finite and countable and
decomposable um I suppose mathematically
but yeah I still I still wake up some
days and go to think to myself what is
an object because it's it's it's a
non-trivial um question persists over
time I'm quoting from the paper here an
object is finite is distinguishable sure
that's a weird adjective
distinguishable we've had so many people
help offering to rewrite the paper after
it came out you wouldn't believe it so
funny persists over time and is
breakable such that the set of of
constraints to construct it from
elementary building blocks is
quantifiable such that the set of
constraints to constructed from
elementary building blocks is
quantifiable the history is in the
objects it's kind of cool right so okay
so what defines the object is it's
history or memory whichever is the
sexier word I'm happy with both
depending on the day okay so the set of
steps it took to create the object so
there's a
sense in which every object in the
universe has a history Y and that is
part of the thing that is used to
describe its complexity how complicated
it is okay what is an assembly index so
the assembly index if you to take the
object apart and be super lazy about it
or minimal say what it because my you
know it's like you've got a really
short-term memory so what you do is you
lay all the Parts on the path and you
find the minimum um number of steps you
take on the path to add the parts
together to to to reproduce the object
and that minimum number is the assembly
index is a minimum bound and it was
always my intuition the minimum Bound in
assembly theory was really important and
I only worked out why a few weeks ago
which is kind of funny because I was
just like no this is Sacra sank I don't
know why it will come to me one day and
then when I was pushed by a bunch of
mathematicians um we we we came up the
the correct physical explanation which I
can get to but it's the minimum and it's
really important it's the minimum and
the reason I knew the minimum was right
is because we could measure it so almost
before this paper came out we've with
published papers explain how you can
measure the assembly index of molecules
okay so that's not so trivial to figure
out so when you look at an object we can
say molecule we can say object more
generally mhm to figure out the minimum
number of steps it takes to create that
that
object that doesn't seem like a trivial
thing to do so with molecules is it's
not trivial but it is possible because
what you can do and because I'm I'm a
chemist so I'm kind of like I see the
lens of the world for just chemistry um
um I break the molecule apart break
bonds and if you break out if you take a
molecule and you break it all apart you
have a bunch of atoms and then you can
say okay I'm going to then Form B take
the atoms and form bonds go up the the
chain of events to make the molecule and
that's what made me realize take a toy
example literally toy example take a
Lego object which is broken up of Lego
blocks so you could do exactly the same
thing in this case the Lego blocks are
naturally the smallest they're the atoms
in the actual composite Lego
architecture but then if you maybe take
you know um a couple of blocks and put
them together in a certain way maybe
they have a they're offset in some way
that offset is on the memory you can use
that offset again with only a penalty of
one and you can then make a square
triangle and keep going and you remember
those motifs on the Chain so you can
then leap from the the start with all
the Lego blocks or atoms just laid out
in front of you and say right I'll take
you you you connect and do the least
amount of work so it's really like uh
the the smallest um um steps you can
take on the graph to make the object and
so for molecules it came relatively
intuitively
and then we started to apply it to
language we've even started to apply it
to mathematical theorems but I'm so well
out of my depth but it looks like you
can take minimum set of axioms and then
start to build up kind of uh
mathematical architectures in the same
way and then the shortest path to get
there is something interesting that I
don't yet understand so what's the
computational complexity of figuring out
the shortest path in um with molecules
with language with mathematical theorems
it seems like once you have the fully
constructed Lego
Castle or whatever your favorite Lego
world is figuring out how to get there
from the building basic building blocks
isn't like a is that an empty hard
problem it's a hard problem it's a hard
problem but actually if you look at it
so the best way to look at it for let's
take a molecule so if the molecule has
um 13 bonds first of all take 13 copies
of the molecule and just cut all the
bonds so take cut 12 bonds and then you
just put them in order yeah and then
that's how it works so and you keep
looking for Symmetry and re or or copies
so you can then shorten it as you go
down and that becomes commentor quite
hard um for some natural product
molecules um it's comes very hard it's
not impossible but we're looking at the
bounds on that at the moment but as the
object gets bigger it becomes really
hard and but there that's the bad news
but the good news is there are shortcuts
and we might even be able to physically
measure the complexity without
computationally calculating it which is
kind of insane wait wait how would you
do that well in the case of molecule um
so if you shine light on a molecule
let's take it infrared the the molecule
has each of the bonds absorbs the
infrared differently in what we call the
fingerprint region and so it's a bit
like a um and because it's quantized as
well you have all these discrete kind of
absorbances and my intuition after we
realized we could cut molecules up in
Mass Spec that was the first go at this
we did it with using infrared and the
infrared gave us an even better
correlation assembly index and we used
another technique as well in addition to
infrared called NMR nuclear magnetic
resonance which tells you about the
number of different magnetic
environments in a molecule and that also
worked out so we have three techniques
which each of them independently gives
us the same or tending towards the same
assembly index for molecule that we can
calculate mathematically okay so these
are all methods of MPC trometry MPC you
scan a molecule it gives you data in the
form of a Mass Spectrum and you're
saying that uh the data correlates to
the assembly index yeah so how
generalizable is that shortcut first of
all to chemistry and second of all
beyond that because that seems like a
nice hack and you're extremely
knowledgeable about various aspects of
chemistry so you can say okay it kind of
correlates but you know the whole idea
behind assembly Theory paper and perhaps
why it's so controversial is that it
reaches
bigger it reaches for the bigger general
theory of objects in the universe yeah
I'd say so I'd agree so I've started
assembly theory of emoticons with my lab
believe it or not so we take emojis yeah
pixelate them and work out the assembly
index for emoji yeah and then work out
how many emojis you can make on the path
of emoji so there's the Uber emoji from
which all other emoj em emojis emerge
yeah and then you can so you can then
take a photograph and by looking at the
shortest path on on by reproducing the
pixels to make the image you want you
can measure that so then you start to be
able to take um spatial data now there's
some problems there what is then the
definition of the object how many pixels
um how do you break it down and so we're
just learning all this right now so how
do you compute the how would you begin
to compute the assembly index of a
graphical like a set of pixels on a 2G
plane that form a thing so you would
first of all determine the resolution so
then how how what is your XY what the
number on the X and Y plane and then
look at the surface area and then you
take all your emojis and make sure
they're all looked at the same
resolution yes and then we will
basically then um do the exact the same
thing we would do for cutting the bonds
you'd cut bits out of the Emoji on and
look at the the you'd have a bag of
pixels so um and you would then add
those pixels together to make the
overall emoji wait wait a minute but
like first of all not every
pixel's I mean this is at the core sort
of machine learning computer vision not
every pixel is that important and
there's like macro features there's
micro features and all that kind of
stuff exactly what like uh you know the
eyes appear in A lot of them the smile
appears in a lot of them so in the same
way in chemistry we assume the bond is
fundamental what we do and there here is
we assume the resolution at the scale of
which we do it is fundamental and we're
just working that out and that you're
right that will change right because as
you take your lens out a bit you it will
change dramatically but it but it's just
a new way of looking at not just
compression what we do right now in
computer science and data one big kind
of um uh um kind of misunderstanding as
assembly theory is telling you about how
compressed the object is that's not
right it say how much information is
required on a chain of events because
the nice thing is if you when you do
compression in computer science we're
wandering a bit here but it's kind of
worth wandering I think in you you um
assume you have instantaneous access to
all the information in the memory yeah
assembly Theory you say no you don't get
access to that memory until you've done
the work and then you access that memory
you can have access but not to the next
one and this is how in assembly Theory
we talk about the four universes the
assembly Universe the assembly possible
and the assembly contingent and then the
assembly observed and they're all all
scales in this combinatorial universe
yeah can you explain each one of them
yep so the assembly universe is like
anything goes just it's just
combinatorial kind of explosion in
everything so that's the biggest one
that's the biggest one it's massive
assembly Universe assembly pass possible
assembly contingent assembly observed
and uh on the Y AIS is assembly steps in
time yeah and you know in the x-axis as
as the thing expands Through Time more
and more unique objects appear so yeah
so assembly universe everything goes yep
um assembly possible laws of physics
come in in this case in chemistry bonds
MH in assembly so that means those are
extra constraints I guess yes and
they're the only straints they're the
constraints at the base the way to look
at is you got all your atoms they're
quanti you can just bung them together
so then you can become a kind of so in
the way in computer science speak I
suppose the assembly universe is just
like no laws of physics things can fly
through mountains beyond the speed of
light in in the assembly possible you
have to apply the laws of physics but
you can get access to all the motifs
instantaneously with no effort so that
means you could make anything then the
assembly contingent says no no you can't
have access to the highly assembled
object in the future until you've done
the work in the past on the causal chain
and that's really the really interesting
shift where you go from assembly um
possible to assembly contingent that is
really the key thing in assembly theory
that says you cannot just have
instantaneous access to all those
memories you have to have done the work
somehow the universe has to have somehow
built a um a system that allows you to
select that path um rather than other
paths and then the final thing the
assembly observed is basically saying oh
these are the things we actually see we
can go backwards now and understand that
they have been created by this this
causal process wait a minute so when you
say the universe has to construct the
system that does the work is that like
the environment that that that allows
for like selection yeah yeah yeah that's
the thing that does The Selection you
could think about in terms of of a Von
noyman Constructor first selection a
ribosome a Tesla plant assembling Teslas
you know the the difference between the
assembly Universe in Tesla land and the
Tesla Factory is everyone says no Teslas
are just easy they just spring out you
know how to make them all the Tesla
Factory you have to put things in
sequence and out comes a Tesla so you're
talking about the factory yes this is
this is really nice super important
point is that when I talk about the
universe having a memory or there's some
magic it's not that it's that that tells
you that there must be a process encoded
somewhere in physical reality be it a
cell a Tesla Factory or something else
that is making that object I'm not
saying there's some kind of woo woo
memory in the universe you know morphic
resonance or something I'm saying that
there is an actual causal process that
is being directed constrained in some
way um so it's not kind of uh just
making everything yeah but the what's
the factory they made the
factory so what what is the so first of
all you assume the laws of physics is uh
just sprung to existence at the
beginning those are constraints but what
what makes the factory the environment
that does The Selection this is the
question of well it's the first
interesting question that I want to
answer out of four I think the factory
emerges in the envir the interplay
between the environment and the object
objects that are being built MH and and
here let me I'll have a go explain to
you the the shortest path so why is the
shortest path important imagine you've
got um I'm going to have to go chemistry
for a moment then abstract it um so
imagine you've got uh an envir a given
environment that um that you have a
budget of atoms you're just flinging
together yep and the the objective of
those atoms that being flung together in
say molecule a um have to make that they
have they decompose so molecules
decompose over time so the
molecules um in this environment in this
magic environment have to not die but
they do die there's a there's they have
a half life so the only way the
molecules can get through that
environment out the other side let
pretend the environment is a box you go
in and out without dying and there's a
there's just an infinite supply of atoms
coming or well a large
Supply the the molecule gets built but
the molecule that is able to template
itself being built um and survives in
the environment will will basically re
Supreme now let's say that molecule
takes 10
steps now and it and it's using a finite
set of atoms right or now let's say
another molecule smart ass molecule
we'll call it comes in yeah and can
survive in that
environment and can copy itself but it
only needs five
steps the molecule that only needs five
steps CU it's Contin both molecules are
being destroyed but they're creating
themselves faster they can be destroyed
you can see that the shortest path reign
supreme so the shortest path tells us
something super interesting about the
minimal amount of uh information
required to propagate that Motif in time
and space um and it's just like a kind
of it seems to be like some kind of
conservation law so one of the
intuitions you have is the propagation
of motifs in time will be done by the
things that can construct themselves in
in the
shortest path yeah so like you can
assume that most of the objects in the
universe are built in the shortest in
the most efficient way that the so big
leap I just took there yeah no yeah yes
and no because there are other things so
in the limit yes because you want to
tell the difference between things that
have required a factory to build them
and just random
processes um but but you can find
instances where the shortest path isn't
taken for an individual object an
individual function MH um and people go
ah that means the shortest path isn't
right and then I say well I don't know I
think it's right still because so of
course because there are other driving
forces it's not just one molecule now
when you start to now you start to
consider two objects you have a joint
assembly space and it's not now it's a
compromise between not just making A and
B in the shortest path you want to make
a and b in the shortest path which might
mean that a is slightly longer you have
compromise so when you see slightly more
nesting in the construction when you
take a given object that can look longer
but that's because the overall function
is the object is still trying to be
efficient yeah and this is still very
hand wavy um and maybe have no leg to
stand on but we think we're getting
somewhere with that and there's probably
some parallelization
yeah right so this is all this not
sequential the building
is I guess when you're when you're
talking about complex objects you you
don't have to work sequentially you can
work in parallel you can get your
friends together and they can yeah these
and the the thing we're working on right
now is how to understand these parallel
processes now there's an in a new thing
we've introduced called assembly depth
and ass assembly depth can be lower than
the assembly index for a molecule
when they're cooperating together CU
exactly this parallel processing is
going on and my team have been working
this out in the last few weeks because
we're looking at what compromises does
nature need to make when it's making
molecules in the cell and I I'm wonder
if you know I I maybe like well I'm
always leaping out of um my competence
but in economics I'm just wondering if
you could apply this in economic process
it seems like capitalism is very good at
finding shortest path M you know every
time but there are ludicrous things that
happen because actually the cost
function has been minimized and so I
keep seeing parallels everywhere where
there are complex nested systems where
if you give it enough time and you
introduce a bit of heterogeneity the
system readjusts and finds a new shorts
path but the shortest path isn't fixed
on just one molecule now it's in the
actual existence of the object over time
and that object could be a city it could
be a cell it could be a factory but I
think we're going Way Beyond molecules
and and my competence and probably
should go back to molecules but
hey